>>Female Presenter: So, on behalf of the Authors@Google
program, I'm really pleased to welcome William
Bennett Turner to speak today with us about
his book, "Figures of Speech: First Amendment
Heroes and Villains." And while reading his
book, all right, this is a used copy [chuckles].
I kept this particular point in mind, a point
that he makes early on that "it's easy to
support free speech when you agree with what's
being said, but a challenge to support another's
right to express ideas one disagrees with
or even loathes. I found myself holding off
judgment till I heard his arguments for each
case he put before us, the beneficiaries of
the First Amendment.
It was an excellent exercise in remaining
open-minded while all sides were being heard."
Turner practiced law for 45 years and has
argued three cases before the US Supreme Court.
He served as a legal affairs correspondent
for KQED television in San Francisco.
He has appeared on Nightline, CBS Morning
News, PBS News Hour, and many other programs.
For 25 years, he taught courses on the First
Amendment at UC Berkeley. And now please join
me in welcoming Bill Turner.
[applause]
>>William Bennett Turner: Hi everybody. I'm
glad to see that there's some interest here
in the First Amendment and in free speech
and freedom of the press. Google's life depends
on it.
Nobody should take these freedoms for granted.
They're what make us a free people and these
freedoms are very fragile. Let me talk a little
bit about the book and then I'd like to say
a word about WikiLeaks and the First Amendment.
First let me introduce you to some of the
characters in the book.
And you can feel free to hiss the villains
and cheer the heroes if you can figure out
who they are.
[laughter]
Citizens United is a non-profit corporation,
conservative politically, that produced a
video hatchet job on Hilary Clinton during
the 2008 primaries. And last year, won the
most important First Amendment decision of
the 21st Century so far, a decision that you're
probably familiar with banking freeing corporations
to buy political ads supporting or opposing
candidates.
Quite different is Yetta Stromberg, who was
a counselor at a summer camp in San Bernardino
for communist families. Children from six
to sixteen attended the camp. And she got
them up every morning and held a pledge of
allegiance to the flag. It was a little red
flag with a hammer and sickle on it.
And she was convicted after the camp was raided.
And all of the adults were arrested. She was
convicted of flying a red flag quote, "as
a symbol of opposition to organized government."
And in 1931, hers was the first case in American
history in which the Supreme Court threw out
a law on First Amendment grounds.
Americans do have a right to oppose organized
government. Dannie Martin, the man on the
left here in the jail clothes, was a heroin
addict and an alcoholic and a very clumsy
bank robber who got caught red-handed and
was sentenced to 33 years in federal prison,
where he discovered a rare talent for writing.
And he wrote a long series of--. Became an
award-winning author of a series of vignettes
of prison life for the San Francisco Chronicle
until he wrote one that was critical of the
prison warden and they lowered the boom. Dannie
said quote, "I committed bank robbery and
they put me in prison and that was right.
Then I committed journalism and they put me
in the hole and that was wrong." Judge Robert
Schnacke, a crusty old Republican judge in
San Francisco, a federal judge, presided over
a trial I did on whether California could
hold executions in secret. And if not, whether
the state could prohibit televising executions.
The judge gave the government the benefit
of the doubt, which is always a mistake in
a First Amendment case. Then there's Earl
Caldwell, the New York Times reporter, who
covered the Black Panther party. He was subpoenaed
by a federal grand jury to disclose all of
his confidential sources and notes.
The Supreme Court ruled that he didn't have
any First Amendment right to protect his sources.
That's the only time in history that the court
has addressed the issue. Richard Hongisto,
which may be a familiar name to you, was first
sheriff of San Francisco and he was somewhat
of a hero in advocating government transparency.
But he then lurched into villain status when
as Chief of Police of San Francisco, he ordered
the cops to confiscate all copies of this
issue of the San Francisco Bay Times. Clarence
Brandenburg, the Ku Klux Klan leader whose
case established the right to advocate bad
ideas, like racial hatred for example.
His case still limits the ability of the government
to restrict terrorist speech. James Madison,
the father of the First Amendment, and Madison
with one of his friends. That was at the National
Constitution Center in Philadelphia where
you can hang out with all of the Founding
Fathers.
They're all in bronze, but it's still interesting
to be with them. Larry Flint. He is no James
Madison. Larry Flint is the world's leading
pornographer whose case against the Reverend
Jerry Falwell, leader of the Moral Majority,
resulted in strong First Amendment protection
for political satire.
After the argument in his case, Flint said,
"If the court will protect a scumbag like
me, then it will protect all of you." And
Clinton Fein, he pronounces his name Feign,
a hero from the digital world, whose adventures
with the First Amendment seem relevant to
Google.
When I first met Clinton, he felt betrayed.
He thought he had been promised freedom of
expression. Instead, he got the Communications
Decency Act. He was born in South Africa and
Clinton grew up under apartheid. When he graduated
from college, he wanted to be a journalist,
but the South Africa at the time wasn't a
very promising environment for young journalists.
So, he emigrated to the United States, studied
up on the Constitution, studied for his citizenship
exams and so on. Learned all about the Constitution
and he was naturalized as a citizen in 1994.
The First Amendment's free speech clause was
what he cared most about.
He wanted to speak on the internet. But Congress
then enacted the Communications Decency Act
of 1996. As a result of this law, Fein would've
had freer speech in then post-apartheid South
Africa than he had in the United States because
his online speech was subject to the act.
The act which we called the CDA was the most
sweeping restriction on the speech of ordinary
citizens that Congress has ever attempted.
It was more threatening to the average person
than the infamous Sedition Act of 1798. It
had two provisions--two main provisions.
One made it a federal crime to communicate
anything quote "indecent" online, knowing
that the communication was to a minor, somebody
17 years of age or younger. The term "indecent"
was not defined at all. The other provision
made it a crime to quote "display" on the
internet anything quote "patently offensive"
if it was quote "available” to a minor,
as virtually everything is of course.
Violation of either of these provisions was
punishable by two years in prison. The ostensible
purpose of the CDA was to shield children
from exposure to indecent online material.
Every politician, of course, wants to protect
America's children from smut.
The CDA was an act of legislative villainy
because any modestly intelligent Congressperson
had to know that this clumsily drafted CDA
violated the First Amendment.
But nobody was willing to say that. Passing
the law meant dumping the responsibility for
saying so on the courts. And the CDA was promptly
challenged by the American Civil Liberties
Union and other organizations. They went to
the federal court, district court in Philadelphia,
which immediately stopped the government from
enforcing the law during the lawsuit.
The court found then that the CDA would criminalize
a vast range of speech that Americans--at
least adults--have a right to engage in. For
example, using any of satirious George Carlin's
famous dirty words from his "Filthy Words"
monologue --shit, piss, fuck, cunt, cocksucker,
and so on--would be a felony if you put it
in an email to your 17-year old little brother,
or made it available on any website that a
minor could access.
Displaying great works of art like Tony Kushner's
Pulitzer Prize winning play "Angels in America,"
which has a lot of rough language and sex
scenes and so on, would be a crime. Magazines
like Wired, that appeared both in print and
online and used some of Carlin's words would
be protected on the news stand, but subject
to criminal prosecution as soon as the editor
pressed the button to post an article online.
At the time the CDA was enacted, Clinton Fein's
day job as a self-taught computer whiz was
constructing and maintaining websites. But
he'd also begun publishing edgy, provocative
material that attracted the government's attention.
And a dispute with the Navy over his using
a Navy recruiting poster, Fein got legal help
from Michael Traynor, who's a prominent San
Francisco lawyer.
At the time, Traynor and I were representing
Wired magazine in various First Amendment-related
matters. And we were concerned about the CDA's
impact. We met with Fein who wanted to challenge
the CDA in any way he could. So, we helped
him have his day in court.
Our main attack was on a provision of the
CDA that it was different from the ones in
ACLU case. It was an update of the old federal
obscene telephone call statute. As part of
the CDA, Congress made it a crime, also punishable
by two years in prison to say online anything
quote "obscene, lewd, lascivious, filthy,
or indecent with intent to annoy another person."
Clinton himself was annoyed and he wanted
to annoy the politicians and prudes who egged
him on. So, he launched a website called annoy.com
[audience chuckles], which he announced was
its own CDA, created and designed to annoy.
Annoy.com had several innovative features.
One of them was called "Heckle." It enabled
site visitors to construct and send email
messages anonymously to various public officials
and public figures. It operated like the Mad
Libs game and invited visitors to criticize
the recipients in the most vulgar and hilarious
terms.
Most of the messages predictably would annoy
whoever received them. For example, one could
compose a letter to then Speaker of the House,
Newt Gingrich. This was one of them on Heckle.
It might say, "Dear Speaker Gingrich. Your
contract with America is brilliant/pile of
shit.
It will save/ruin America. It will benefit
all Americans/only the rich. You are truly
a genius/an asshole."
[laughter]
The problem with annoy.com was that if the
CDA was constitutional, Clinton then was subject
to criminal prosecution for violating both
the prohibition on posting indecency and the
online communication of quote "indecent material
with intent to annoy."
So, we mounted a two-pronged attack. First,
we filed a brief amicus curiae, a friend of
the court brief in the United States Supreme
Court, in the ACLU suit. And there, we attacked
the constitutionality of the CDA itself. Second,
we filed our own suit against Attorney General
Janet Reno, in federal court in San Francisco,
seeking to adjoin her from enforcing the "intent
to annoy" law.
Janet Reno was my law school classmate and
it's hard for me to believe that she could
believe the arguments that her underlings
made on her behalf to support the CDA. This
is one of Clinton Fein's creations of Janet
Reno.
Our case was a lot stronger, actually, than
the ACLU's because the law we were challenging
had nothing to do with children. The government
couldn't defend it on the ground that it was
needed to protect children from indecency.
It was a flat out ban on speech that adults
have every right to communicate.
The fact that a communication is made with
intent to annoy can't save the law. Speech
doesn’t lose First Amendment protection
by offending its audience. The government
delayed--forever, it seemed--delayed responding
to our suit as long as it could, arguing that
the ACLU's case would likely affect the issues
in our case.
And the ACLU case hadn't been decided yet.
The government insisted though, on its right
to prosecute Fein for any violations of the
annoy law that occurred while the case was
delayed. The court in San Francisco agreed
with the government to defer any ruling until
Reno v. ACLU came down, leaving Fein at risk
if he continued to operate annoy.com.
He continued. On June 26, 1997, the Supreme
Court decided Reno v. ACLU. It was a wonderful
decision. A landmark of First Amendment freedom
and a charter of liberty for the internet.
You ought to keep a copy of it under your
pillow. The opinion was written by Justice
John Paul Stevens and it qualifies him for
candidacy in the pantheon of First Amendment
heroes.
Reno v. ACLU was the court's first internet
case. It was a new medium of communication
for the court. And nobody could know how the
court would apply First Amendment rules to
it. In the past, when confronted with a new
medium, the court had sometimes fumbled.
For example, when movies were invented and
became commercial, the court in 1915 allowed
cities to censor them at will, reasoning that
movies were just a business like any other
and subject to local regulation, not protected
by any speech or press guarantees.
That ruling wasn't overruled until 1952. And
the court also botched the job when it first
encountered cable television. But Stevens
got it right in the ACLU case. His opinion
first laid out in detail how the internet
actually works. Seventy-seven years old at
the time.
He retired last year at 90. But at the time
of this decision, he was 77. And he casually
observed that quote "navigating the web is
relatively straight-forward." And this was
pre-Google.
[laughter]
Stevens then dealt with the government's argument
that the internet should be treated like broadcast,
subject to government regulation like the
FCC's regulation of radio and broadcast television.
Indeed, the government argued that what it
called the "indecency problem" on the internet
is much more pronounced than it is on broadcast
stations.
This was because, they said, the internet
operates quote "without the intervention of
editors, network censors, or market disincentives."
In other words, the government argued that
because ordinary citizens could communicate
with each other directly, not as the passive
recipients of programming directed at them
by broadcasters and commercial sponsors, the
government has to step in to police indecent
material.
In my view, the perverse result of that would
be that the more democratic the medium free
of commercial censors, the greater the government's
right to regulate the medium. But Stevens
demolished the government's argument pointing
out that broadcast regulation lied on the
unique characteristics of the broadcast medium--the
scarcity of frequencies on the electromagnetic
spectrum, the long history of government regulation
in allocating frequencies and requiring that
licensees act in the public interest, and
the invasive nature of the medium.
Stevens said, "These factors are not present
in cyberspace" finding that the content on
the internet is as diverse as human thought.
Stevens concluded that internet speech is
at least as free as speech in newspapers,
in books, or on soap boxes. The court then
found the law unconstitutional.
It was vague in the sense that no one could
know exactly what was prohibited. Congressman
Weiner's wiener? Who knows? And it was over-broad
in the sense that it swept within its criminal
prohibition speech that the First Amendment
protects at least among adults.
And trying to protect children from indecent
material, Stevens said the government may
not reduce the adult population to quote "only
what is fit for children." The level of internet
discourse cannot be limited to that suitable
for a sandbox. Since there are alternative
ways to shield children from exposure to unwanted
internet material, like parents installing
filters, for example.
The government failed to justify criminalizing
the internet speech of ordinary citizens.
Finally, Justice Stevens made short shrift
of the government's last ditch, desperate,
Hail Mary argument that wait a minute. We
have another interest, not just the interest
in protecting children but we have an equally
significant interest in quote "fostering the
growth of the internet as a communications
medium."
The government argued that the easy availability
of indecent material on the internet was quote
"driving countless citizens away from the
medium because of the risk of exposing themselves
or their children to harmful material."
Justice Stevens responded, "The dramatic expansion
of this new marketplace of ideas shows the
government is just plain wrong. The growth
of the internet has been and continues to
be phenomenal."
More importantly, Justice Stevens said as
a First Amendment matter, "We presume that
government regulation of the content of speech
is more likely to interfere with the free
exchange of ideas than to encourage it. The
interest in encouraging freedom of expression
in a democratic society outweighs any theoretical
unproven benefit of censorship."
The CDA was thus given a decent burial. And
the most democratic means of communication
ever invented allowed to flourish. Well, in
light of Reno v. ACLU, Clinton Fein's case
on the annoy provision looked like a slam
dunk. The Supreme Court had proclaimed an
indecent online speech couldn't be made criminal.
And in our case, the government couldn't even
argue that it had a need to protect children.
But instead of graciously conceding that the
annoy provision was unconstitutional, Janet
Reno's underlings came up with a shameless
interpretation of the law that would rescue
it.
The government now claimed that the law didn't
mean what it said. It did not, in fact, outlaw
indecent communications at all. The government
said the provision prohibiting quote "obscene,
lewd, lascivious, filthy, or indecent communications
was limited to obscene communications."
Therefore, the government said since Clinton
Fein wasn't in the business of putting obscene
material online, the law didn't apply to him
and his case should be dismissed. Lemme remind
you what obscenity is.
Something is obscene if it falls within the
three-part definition of obscenity established
by the Supreme Court in a case called Miller
v. California, 1973. In order to be obscene,
that's a category of speech that has no First
Amendment protection at all. In order to be
obscene, it has to appeal predominantly to
the prurient interest-- the interest in sexual
arousal.
Secondly, it has to be patently offensive
in its depiction of sexual or excretory acts.
And third, it has to lack serious political,
scientific, literary, or artistic value. All
three things have to be true in order for
the material to be obscene. It's a very small
category of outlawed speech.
The first two, none of this makes any sense.
But the first two things, that has to appeal
to the prurient interest, it has to turn you
on, one professor has said. The second thing
says it has to gross you out. It has to be
patently offensive. It has to do both. It
has to both turn you on and gross you out.
It doesn't make any sense. Anyway, that's
what obscenity is.
[laughter]
The government hardly prosecutes any obscenity
cases anymore. They're hard core, bestiality
rape scenes and violent videos and stuff.
They rarely trouble with obscene cases.
And Clinton Fein clearly wasn't putting anything
obscene online. Well, the government's new
definition of the annoy law was ridiculous.
Obscenity already was prohibited in any medium
of communication, so the government's interpretation
would render the law meaningless.
Alas, two of the three district judges on
the court agreed with the government using
Reno's interpretation as a convenient way
to avoid declaring the whole law unconstitutional.
Since Fein didn't challenge the prohibition
of obscenity the judges dismissed his case.
But since the district court decision applied
only here in Northern California, and Fein's
communications were available all over the
country, he remained at risk of prosecution
elsewhere where other courts might read the
law to mean what it actually said.
All internet users would be living under a
cloud, and an uncertain cloud, of a law that
on its face made indecent, annoying communications
a felony. So, we took the case on direct appeal
to the Supreme Court. And on April 19th, 1999,
the court handed down what had to be the shortest
First Amendment decision ever, quote "The
judgment is affirmed."
No explanation. It was a terribly disappointing
outcome and waste of several years of litigation
during which the government never suggested
limiting the law to obscenity. There was a
sliver of a silver lining. The Supreme Court's
action had the effect of making the district
court interpretation binding nationally.
It was now the law of the land. So, in practical
terms the litigation got Clinton Fein what
he needed, the ability to communicate material
that might be considered indecent and to annoy
recipients without fear of criminal prosecution.
What he didn't get but deserved was a ringing
affirmation that the CDA annoy provision violated
the First Amendment.
After the demise of the CDA, the Congress
attempted three other laws attempting to restrict
online sexual content. They've only tried
to address sexual content on the internet.
The only kind of content Congress has ever
attempted to regulate. One of the laws, you
may remember, was about virtual child pornography.
But only one of the laws, not the one on child
pornography, only one of the laws survived
in the Supreme Court. It required public and
school libraries to install software filters
to screen out material that may be quote "harmful
to minors." No definition of what that meant.
And in a case ominously named United States
of America v. The American Library Association,
the Supreme Court upheld the law on the reasoning
that Congress could put strings on the subsidies
that it chooses to give. Government doesn't
have to fund libraries, but if it does it
can put conditions on the funding.
At the argument in the case, the government
lawyer was asked by one of the Justices, "Well,
what if an adult in a public library wants
to get access to some site and it's blocked?
Doesn't that deny him the full resources of
the internet?" And the government lawyer said
to the court, "No. Upon request of an adult
user, a librarian will come running and unblock
the site or disable the filter."
And on the basis of that kind of wishful thinking
the court upheld the library law. Whether
software filters solve these kinds of First
Amendment internet problems is an interesting,
amusing diversion.
In the Library case, the government urged
that filters are effective in protecting children
from exposure to harmful material, while it
was the civil libertarians who argue that
the filters over block and under block and
the government has no business policing libraries
anyway.
In the CDA case and other internet cases,
these roles were reversed. The ACLU argued
that filters were effective and a less restrictive
means of protecting children than criminal
prosecutions, while the government argued
that filters were ineffective and they needed
the criminal sanction.
This seeming inconsistency was nicely resolved
by Ann Beeson of the ACLU, who said the central
issue is whose finger is on the mouse, the
parents or the government? When a parent installs
a filter that keeps a kid from seeing a bunch
of sites that may or may not be pornography,
that's parenting.
When government forces all adults and minors
to use filters, that's censorship. The broader
issue in all of this is whether the courts
ought to accept the government's assertion
that it has a compelling interest in protecting
minors from material that it considers harmful.
The government has not been required to prove
that minors are in fact injured by hearing
dirty words or seeing sexual images. If we
uncritically assume that the government has
a compelling interest in shielding children
from speech it says is harmful, what's to
prevent legislators from enacting say a literature
decency act, or a law banning profanity, or
bad grammar, or Facebook?
All of those may be harmful to children in
somebody's eyes. Well, undaunted by his adventures
with the legal system, our hero, Clinton Fein
continues now to rail against politicians
and powerful corporations using both annoy.com
and art.
He's become a renowned digital artist and
he's a direct beneficiary of Larry Flint's
case against Jerry Falwell and its protection
for offensive satire and vicious political
cartooning. Working with a computer and a
digital camera, Fein has created political
cartoons, collages, and other images that
offend their targets and many others.
Here are a few. An attack on using emaciated
fashion models. This ad for a gallery show
that Clinton did depicts former Mayor Rudy
Giuliani, sitting naked in a urine-filled
glass, referencing Giuliani’s denial of
funding for the Brooklyn Museum when he was
Mayor.
Art Forum, the magazine, refused to run the
ad. Fein savagely attacked the George W. Bush
Administration at every opportunity, especially
the invasion of Iraq and the Abu Ghraib torture.
One of his images shows the President nailed
to the cross, crucifixion-style with an erection
popping out of his loin cloth in the shape
of a rocket, under the banner "Who would Jesus
torture?"
The printer for an art gallery show found
that Fein's image was offensive and destroyed
it. This sort of censorship, of course, does
not violate the First Amendment because only
the government can violate the First Amendment.
The Constitution binds only the government,
not private entities--people, churches, corporations
of any kind.
Only the government can violate the Constitution.
Nor does this kind of censorship dampen Fein's
willingness to exercise the freedom of expression
that brought him to this country. His imagery
sometimes is sexual. It includes anuses and
erect penises and George Carlin-esque words
describing them.
He says his mother "wishes I would do water
colors." A First Amendment true believer,
he keeps on poking at hypocrisy and blasting
the mainstream media for laziness and cowardice.
Now, let me say a word about WikiLeaks and
the First Amendment. On the fortieth anniversary
of the publication of the Pentagon Papers,
today, June the 13th, Julian Assange arrived
on the scene just too late to make this book.
Where is this book anyway? You took my copy.
>>Female Presenter: [inaudible]
>>William Bennett Turner: A dog-eared copy.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
>>William Bennett Turner: Yeah, well Julian
Assange didn't show up in time. Is he a First
Amendment hero or a villain? When he was interviewed
on 60 Minutes recently, he wrapped himself
in the First Amendment.
And he said about WikiLeaks quote, "Our founding
values are those of the American Revolution,
those of Jefferson and Madison." Assange may
not know that our Constitution was written
in secret in that hot summer in Philadelphia
in 1787, behind closed doors guarded by sentries.
There were no leaks. We like to think of ourselves
as an open society with a transparent government,
but in fact we have a long history of government
secrecy and constitutional tolerance of that
secrecy.
Here's my two cents worth on WikiLeaks and
the First Amendment. My thesis is this: WikiLeaks
basically owes its existence to two weaknesses
in First Amendment protection for speech and
the press. Both of the weaknesses stem from
bad Supreme Court decisions that I unfortunately
had something to do with.
The rulings were that there is no constitutional
right of access by either press or public
to government information or facilities. That's
Houchins v. KQED, one of the stories in the
book. The other was that reporters don't have
any First Amendment right to protect their
confidential sources against compelled disclosure.
That's Earl Caldwell's case, also in the book.
If we had a constitutional right to know what
our governments up to and reporters could
honestly promise whistle-blowers confidentiality,
which WikiLeaks provides, who needs WikiLeaks?
I hope you won't think this is just sour grapes
because I was on the losing side of these
cases.
I'm not trying to say, "If they'd only listened
to me, we wouldn't have WikiLeaks." It's not
that at all. It's just a recognition that
our First Amendment rights are not as strong
as they ought to be. To the extent that WikiLeaks
informs us citizens, what the government is
doing in our name and does what the mainstream
media can't do guarantee confidentiality for
whistle-blowers.
It partially repairs these flaws in First
Amendment protection. Of course, the government
always has plausible reasons for keeping secrets
and restricting speech and in all of the cases
in the book, the government argued that some
competing value--might be National Security,
protection of privacy, shield our children
from harmful material, whatever--some competing
value and an important competing value requires
or justifies a restriction on speech.
It's the collision of these competing values
that makes First Amendment cases so hard and
so interesting. As for WikiLeaks, the government
is considering prosecution of Assange for
violating the Espionage Act. You remember
that Daniel Ellsberg was prosecuted when he
leaked the Pentagon Papers to the New York
Times exactly 40 years ago.
If Assange is prosecuted, it will be another
epic First Amendment battle. No publisher
has ever been prosecuted for violating the
Espionage Act. However the First Amendment
issues play out, let's hope our own government's
hands are clean.
The Ellsberg prosecution was dismissed in
mid-trial when the judge discovered that President
Nixon's plumbers unit, trying to stop leaks,
had burglarized Ellsberg's psychiatrist’s
office in an attempt to dig up dirt on Ellsberg.
We have no evidence that the Obama White House
was complicit in developing the sexual misconduct
charges against Assange after WikiLeaks' three
big disclosures last year. It may be just
a coincidence that following immediately upon
the disclosures, our friend Sweden issued
an extraordinary international arrest warrant
seeking Assange's extradition on a charge
of failing to use a promised condom.
There can't have been many instances of using
that kind of heavy legal artillery for such
a charge. Companies that supported the WikiLeaks
site, like PayPal, Amazon, and Visa and MasterCard,
may have decided independently without any
government prompting to withdraw their support.
And hacker attacks on WikiLeaks servers may
have been orchestrated by freelancers without
any government encouragement. It would be
really distressing to learn that our government
was involved in any of this. Imagine the irony
if government complicity were established
by secret government documents someday to
be leaked by WikiLeaks.
So, questions about WikiLeaks, about these
internet cases, or anything in the book, or
whatever you wanna talk about? I'll be here.
[applause]
Thank you.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: I have a question
for you about filters, a different sort of
filter, like top-level domain XXX, or kids.com,
which I think was in a concurrence or dissent
of ACLU v. Reno.
What do you think of them or what would be
the legal arguments against having those as
part of government's efforts to censor the
internet?
>>William Bennett Turner: This sound system
sounds like you're out in left field somewhere.
And I'm having trouble getting that. But filters
and you said--
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Yeah. Just like
using top-level domains like XXX, or dot kids,
to establish like a sort of physical--. The
analog of physical zoning. Like, what do you
think of it? How would you argue against it?
>>William Bennett Turner: Yeah, well if the
government requires it, that invites First
Amendment litigation. If the government says,
"You have to be over here," they're regulating
the content of your speech.
And that triggers the requirement that the
government show a compelling interest in that
restriction and that the restriction is narrowly
tailored to serve that interest. I doubt serious--.
Well, I don't think anybody's proposing that
the government require that kind of zoning,
XXX domain names and so on.
I understand that the pornographers are on
both sides of this. They want people to stumble
into their sites accidentally. They don't
want to be segregated--some of them. And some
of them want to be liberated to put whatever
they want without people getting mad at them
or getting interfered with by filters and
so on.
That's a business choice. It's not a legal
problem.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: So, on a personal
level, do you believe that First Amendment
rights are an inalienable human right, or
just a cultural distinction that Americans
have?
[laughter]
>>William Bennett Turner: Say it again.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Oh yes. So, do
you personally believe that First Amendment
rights are a basic human right or a cultural
right for Americans and other such democratic
nations? Like, a cultural distinction.
>>William Bennett Turner: No, I think there's
nearly universal agreement that free speech
is a human right and it's recognized by every
constitution in the world that I've ever heard
of.
The Constitution of North Korea, Cuba, that
are completely oppressive, recognize it and
all of the United Nations declaration of rights
and all of the international treaties recognize
free speech as a basic human right.
Whether the countries live up to the lip service
that they give to these rights in their constitution
is an entirely different matter. Not unique
to the United States by any means. In fact,
and this will be a little sobering to you,
there are organizations that rank the countries
of the world in terms of their free speech
and press and so on.
The United States and the organization that
you're most familiar with called Freedom House,
started by Eleanor Roosevelt back just after
World War II. And they rank all the countries
in the world by how free they are every year.
Their most recent report ranked the United
States not first, not second, tied for 24th.
[laughter]
With the Czech Republic, behind countries
like Estonia and Jamaica and so on. And ranked
right up at the top in freedom of the press,
in particular, are all the Scandinavian countries.
Iceland and Finland seem to trade off One
and Two year after year. It's all of them.
Part of it has to do with the structure of
our media. Part of it has to do with the decline
of the newspaper industry here. In Finland,
for example, a great majority of the population
reads on paper two newspapers a day.
Unheard of in this country. They just care
more about those values than we seem to. Yes,
sir.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: The state of Tennessee
recently passed a bill that--. The state of
Tennessee recently passed a bill that would
fine a person who posts an image that's online
that someone finds offensive. Do you have
any remarks about that? Or do you think that
bill is long for this world?
>>William Bennett Turner: I'm not familiar
with the Tennessee bill. If all it does is
say you can't post an image that is offensive,
that is on its face unconstitutional. As I
say, offensiveness is protected by the First
Amendment.
Many, many cases saying that the fact that
something is offensive, is highly offensive,
doesn't deprive the speech of First Amendment
protection. And that law will not survive
scrutiny for more than a minute.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: You mentioned in
the Reno v. ACLU case that part of the ruling
was based on internet not sharing the unique
properties of broadcast.
>>William Bennett Turner: Right.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Do you foresee
a return to that question now that internet
is increasingly access through potentially
regulated spectrum?
>>William Bennett Turner: Potentially regulated
spectrum such as--
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I mean like cell
phone, wireless connection.
>>William Bennett Turner: No, I don't. I think
one of the benefits of having a totally corporate
business-oriented majority on the Supreme
Court these days is that they are anti-regulation.
The five conservatives on the court all came
to Washington as part of the Reagan revolution,
"Let's get government off our backs." And
one of the items that the Reagan Administration
attacked right on was the Fairness Doctrine,
which used to be imposed by the FCC on licensed
broadcasters.
They got rid of that. They abandoned that.
And I don't detect any sentiment on the court
for endorsing legislation now that would return
the internet to any kind of regulation about
what can be and what can't be done in the
way of content. One slightly worrisome thing
is the convergence factor, as you mentioned,
where the various media converge and become
one.
We get everything out of one place--a device,
or whatever it is. That opens up the argument
that there ought to be the government regulation
of the FCC, for example. They still police
indecency. CBS got fined several hundred thousand
dollars for showing a nanosecond of Janet
Jackson's breast at the halftime show of Super
Bowl.
The FCC's still in that business. They may
be put out of it this year in a case that's
pending in New York, but the FCC is still
policing the air waves. It comes over the--.
Not cable. They don't police content on cable,
but on over-the-air radio and television broadcast.
The FCC's still in that business. As media
converge, would they likely extend that? I
don't think so. I don't think they could get
away with it.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: I got the impression
that you feel that the First Amendment should
have protected WikiLeaks. And I was wondering--.
I don't know if that's true, but I was wondering
if there, is there any type of government
information that you think it shouldn't protect
for divulging? For example, suitcase atomic
weapons or whatever.
>>William Bennett Turner: Yeah, sure. No,
obviously there are real, genuine needs for
government to keep some secrets. Unfortunately,
government doesn't do a very good job on keeping
secrets.
And they use that classified stamp in a libertine
way. I mean, they just classify so much, the
classification becomes meaningless. If Private
Bradley Manning, who's the alleged leaker
to WikiLeaks, was in fact the leaker, he had
a security clearance that gave him access
to all of those classified documents.
He shared that clearance with 500 thousand
other people. How do you expect to keep a
secret that 500 thousand people have access
to? You're right in thinking WikiLeaks ought
to have, that I think, WikiLeaks ought to
have a First Amendment defense to violating
the Espionage Act, but that depends on facts
that I don't know.
Wouldn't you like to hear the conversation
between Assange and Manning? Because I think
a lot depends on how WikiLeaks got the information.
If they got the files over the transom as
we used to say, passively, they didn't do
anything. They were just dumped in their lap.
And then published them on the internet. That's
just like the New York Times in the Pentagon
Papers case. But if Assange and WikiLeaks
actively solicited the leaks, paid the leaker,
provided software assistance to the leaker
and so on, then probably they can be charged
with conspiracy, which is a prosecutor's favorite.
And they're more like Ellsberg in that situation.
They're the actual--. They stand in the same
shoes as the actual government employee who
betrayed his trust. But we don't know what
conversation, if any. I mean, Assange denies
that there was any conversation.
He denies knowing who Manning was until his
name was published in the press later on.
So good is WikiLeaks encryption technology,
even the people at WikiLeaks don't know who
they're dealing with.
>>Female Presenter: Well, on that note, thank
you very much for coming.
[applause]